MIKE: This guy saved everything.
Plus he had a lot
of stuff mixed in.
He had this stuff in trailers.
You could tell this stuff hasn't
been touched for a long time.
If you walk into a place,
and there's a lot of stuff
on display, that's easy.
I don't want to
take the easy route.
I want to find this stuff.
I want to discover it.
I love this hippo.
This hippopotamus is a spring
loaded playground ride.
You got the camel.
You got the monkey.
You get the walrus.
Saddle Mates made in
Litchfield, Michigan.
I always wanted the motorcycle.
If some other kid
was on the motorcycle
and I didn't get it
within two minutes,
there were tears coming
down this little kid's face.
Jack, talk to me.
They bring pretty
good dollars.
What's pretty good dollars?
300 range.
Think you're right.
The hippo we picked
up from a playground
that we took out somewhere.
MIKE: We picked a lot
of guys that do demo.
And if you have a
good eye, you can
find some really great stuff.
JACK: We've been in
business a long time
and I take my work personally.
I walk through the collection.
I can say, that job
I got that from.
That job I got that from.
It's a personal thing to me.
MIKE: So if three bills is
retail, where you got to be?
I'm around two I guess.
$150.
Meet me in the middle.
What's the middle?
Want me to calculate
that out for you, Mike?
That's $175.
Oh.
$160.
All right.
We doing this?
We doing it.
MIKE: We doing it.
This is cast aluminum
with a steel coil spring.
I'm falling in love
with this thing.
Cool.
Jack, where did this come from?
It was an old double
decker bus that my dad and I
bought up in Massachusetts.
MIKE: Oh, yeah.
Look at it.
Liverpool, Piccadilly--
JACK: Chelsea.
MIKE: Highbury.
Good old English names.
MIKE: Cabbage junction.
If the route of the bus changed,
then the Marquis had to change.
All right.
So this is on a scroll.
It's rolling.
And if you're standing
at the bus stop
and you want to go
to Nottingham, well,
if it says Nottingham,
that's where you go.
So how long ago did you guys get
rid of the double decker bus?
Oh, it's been a
good 10, 15 years ago.
MIKE: People are making coffee
houses out of those now.
JACK: Yeah.
MIKE: Oh, man.
Did it run?
- Yeah.
I wish I had it back.
- I know.
Cast iron phone booths.
Big Ben.
The double decker bus.
This thing takes you
back to that time period.
They still use these
today, but they're digital.
This is back when it was
paper on cheesecloth.
It's not in really good shape.
Whoops.
It's in worse shape
since I handled it.
Well, he's got to buy it now.
MIKE: What are you
thinking on this?
This piece and the other one.
I don't know.
Want me to make
you an offer on it?
JACK: Make me an offer.
50 bucks.
I would have said 10,
but you can pay me 50.
MIKE: I threw out
50 bucks and he
was nice enough to take my money
because basically, I ruined it.